we were talking about like what is
digital media literacy exactly cuz like
we talked about this a lot and I think
what it really is is not so much being
proficient in scripting and filming and
editing it's just the self-awareness to
know what you're good at and what you're
not mm-hmm good at and just the
appreciation for what goes into things
and and the knowledge of who to tap into
to help you create a project or help you
communicate something because oh yeah
good oh I just have a question because
I'm not plugged into the MIT community
or the or the or even into the
scientific community for that matter but
is there a culture of sort of
individuality where we're in the this
notion that basically what I my
intellectual work is to be done sort of
in a silo versus the kind of like I know
I know I'm not good at this so I need to
build a team where we can build you know
at MIT it's I mean it's pretty
interdisciplinary yeah what I would say
is is not siloed but it is there there's
an ingrained culture of is this idea
that like real science Sammy I'm doing
it now by saying real science that
science and engineering is work and
communication is not work oh I see or
even that it's a separate thing yeah
yeah yeah so that's the that's the you
know it's not that people are like
siloed within themselves it's that that
you know that communicators don't have
street cred with scientists period well
and that that part will just happen it
will take care of itself I'm not going
to worry about it too I see ya so that's
the real that sounds like the real meat
of what you guys are trying to work on
in a way like yeah i guess i guess i
mean it's it's interesting because like
I gave a survey to the students at the
end of the class and they were all like
I probably wouldn't make another video
again a couple of them said they would
but most of them were like I probably
you know won't make a video but like I
have so much more appreciation for what
goes into it and like now I can't watch
a movie without thinking about how much
you know how much
work it took to just light the scene so
just even just having the appreciation
for what goes into it I think is a big
step but again with the whole literacy
thing just the awareness of how
important these these skills are because
like you said I mean it's just crazy
that we think of them as separate things
that like there's science and then
there's communication and you're trained
separately on these things if you happen
to be a science communicator one of the
things that I think is really
interesting about media is that you know
video or media films there they're
really interesting in that there's when
they're well-made there so accessible
they're so immediately graspable by
those of us anyone in the last hundred
years who's really you know literate at
unpacking video and understanding the
medium there's they're so kind of
intuitively open that people who don't
have any appreciation or awareness of
how they're made assume that there isn't
any kind of effort behind them that they
just kind of happen and I can remember
you know as a kid kind of thinking that
you know never really thinking about
movies and how they were made until I
was probably God in college yeah just
kind of assuming that they just kind of
happened out there our clients think you
just hit a button exactly ya know
exactly because and that's because if if
things are well made it's like God like
you did not do it didn't that just
always exist that way I mean somebody
actually had to create that I it seems
so natural and and I think that one of
the things you know a key of media
literacy is understanding you know kind
of breaking that myth right or gasp it
would cost money to you would have to
train you get to hire professionals to
do it that are trained and pay them so
the biggest thing and teaching this
literacy though I think is making them
go through the experience themselves
right because it's one thing if you
watch like a series of lectures like
it's one thing if you watch this on
OpenCourseWare and you you can take the
notes on like this is good framing if
you use the two-thirds rule like you
know write a script like you would say
like we go through all these sort of
tangible take-home points he's like
class
elements like you mentioned but I don't
think you'll have the same you won't
draw the same value from it as if you
actually go through and try to do the
projects that these students did and
that's a big issue I think especially in
immediate teaching that it's easy to
first establish a sort of theoretical
principles like this is sort of what
makes a good story and then and then
it's another thing to actually give hard
like tangible examples to students like
look at this script there they were able
to point out issues in the scripts they
were able to critique them but then it's
a whole nother step for them to be able
to integrate it themselves into a script
so you'd have a student who like
understood the principle they took the
notes they could reiterate everything he
said to them they were able to look at
the examples you gave them and say oh
you know this is unclear here this this
is awkward wording and then they would
write the script and you'd be like you
know there's a disconnect dilute the
instep and it wasn't until they tried it
and then we were able to critique them
directly that they were able to come to
this you know final self-awareness
conclusions